あもうなぁが二人になってるなーすげーで不足だった最近弟いい睡眠時間0
昨日2時間や時をちょっと濡れたんですけどやっぱもうほぼに設置するとね1回寝る
だけちょっと体力回復しないんで今日はちょっと1日寝てましたはじめ社長です
みんなちゃんと寝た方がいいよ本当に相手行度がは毎月恒例質問コーナーのボス江戸三
茶
ハーイだめだちゃんとへの質問コーナー募集の動画で
今月ちょっと趣向を変えていこうと思ってますでいつもだと
youtube のコメント欄にコメントしてねってこうやるんですけど境地が今日は
違う今回は twitter のほうで募集しようと思います僕のツイッターな方は
こちらでございまーすイェーイ
あーマテマテリプライを送るザリプライを送るんじゃないか僕が twitter に
コメントじゃなくてハッシュタグをつけてツイートしてください僕のツイッターに質問
くると皆さんのツイッター
ん
うーんとりあえずハッシュタグをつけて6円の質問と化リクエスト
一言コメントなんでもいいんでハッシュタグをつけてつぶやくて僕が絶対確認します
安心してくださいなんだかなハッシュタグアッシュタグ
ハッシュタグ8 the がはじめ質問コーナー
なんかもっと品チネリが欲しいなんてできますよね8周だけはじめ冊をソニック歳
スクールにしましょうだけで今回はこっち話ですはじめしゃちょー車2回打った後に僕
の質問とかねコメント何でもいいので帰ってくださいあ僕のツイッターよつくらじゃ
ないんですよもうほんと発車だけでつべてくれるだけで可能にするので本当にそういう
感じで言っていきましょう
3月号より
ゆっくりでは寝たいよへと twitter ハッシュタグ質問の起源なんですけども
3月の15日3月の15日の24時までにします3月の15日までにツイッター良かっ
たハッシュタグ付けてコメント書きまくってくださいまあ何回の入りや暴言は何でも
映えて
ちょっと嫌だなぁもう平和ほどほどにしてくれればありがたいですよあったらもう何で
も書いてください質問じゃなくてもいいしリピすればいい
もうモンケンはタンといっしょ本で何でも書いちゃってください本当にもなんでもいい
んでというわけでうえで3月の質問コーナー室も募集してるのでも皆さんの政府に任せ
ますもう何でも書いちゃってくださいもうこれパシッとやりますかもうたんだとの最終
日だ3月の31
日までに出します3月の最終日に多分はじめ者庁舎2階の動画が出るのですねほんと
ちょっと阿蘇
決めてセンスいい人多いからね俺は知ってるはコメント欄で何度笑ったことが今回の
ちょっとキミ達の素晴らしいセンス伝えしてコメントをお待ちしております真面目な
質問でもいいですしもうめちゃくちゃ面白い質問でもいいです
僕の気分で描かせていただくんです良かったらみなさんの質
お待ちしておりますこちらだ後年
ここ
ここですから発車たく twitter ねえチューブのコメントじゃないよ
ここですから始め社長謝肉祭で年ちょいやることが多くてくれず筋肉痛を治して
しっかり寝てすぐなくプルートゥ
ゲームもほどほどにしてね良かったらみなさんのコメントお待ちしておりますよ
おやすみもう今日体バキバキにすぐ出るよ
ん